[Música]
y también hablamos de salud en directo
américa ya está conmigo en el estudio
más romeros a la mar bienvenida feliz
martes vamos a empezar hablando en la
desigualdad lamentablemente en la
distribución de las vacunas contra el
cubit 19 porque hay cifras de las
organizaciones sociales cómo están estas
cifras más esas son varias
organizaciones sociales también voces de
expertos que han publicado un nuevo
informe ahora detallaremos las cifras
justo antes de escuchemos un poco cuál
ha sido también el llamado de atención
de estas organizaciones a los gobiernos
por esta distribución tan inequitativa
de las vacunas en todo el mundo y algo
que pues muchos consideran que va a
hacer que no se termine la pandemia
pronto escuchemos lo
y más de 5 millones de personas han
muerto por kobe 19 la economía global ha
sufrido un golpe de billones de dólares
y ahora estamos en una situación absurda
donde países de europa vuelven a las
cuarentenas por un movimiento anti
vacunas a la vez que los países donde
trabajamos como comité internacional de
rescate tienen porcentajes de vacunación
inferiores al 5 por ciento es un fracaso
de calado global
este informe que han publicado las
organizaciones sociales y voces expertas
juntadas en el panel independiente para
la preparación y para la respuesta
destaca básicamente que la mortalidad en
los países de ingresos bajos ha
aumentado desproporcionadamente si se
compara con el aumento de mortalidad por
competición en los países de ingresos
altos precisamente esa cifra es el 338
por ciento de aumento en los países de
ingresos bajos casi el triple de lo que
sucede con los países de ingresos altos
una desigualdad muy fuerte y
precisamente además de eso también
sucede pues por esa distribución
inequitativa de las vacunas no en esta
franja de los países sin recursos se han
distribuido cuatro vacunas cuatro dosis
de vacunas por cada 100 personas algo
que no tiene nada que ver con las cifras
que manejamos en los países del norte
global este informe además llega a justo
una semana antes de que la organización
mundial del comercio se reúna para
hablar de liberar las patentes de las
vacunas y de los tratamientos contra el
kobe 19 por eso también hay varias
organizaciones que se están sumando para
pedir a los gobiernos y pedir a las
farmacéuticas que esas patentes se
liberen algo que muchos también
consiguen es indispensable para poner
fin a la pandemia y hacer esa vacuna más
accesible qué pasa que la industria
farmacéutica y algunos países
precisamente de estos países ricos se
oponen por ejemplo alemania que alberga
ballón tecno la mitad de la vacuna the
fighter variantes pues porque están
haciendo beneficios al final millonarios
también con estas vacunas que se venden
en todo el mundo marc por favor
explíqueme una cosa el gobierno de kenia
ha sido implementar una especie de pase
sanitario le pregunto si estamos
hablando de esta desigualdad de las
vacunas pues cómo está entonces genia en
esta distribución de la vacuna y cómo
van a implementar un pase sanitario
exacto es un ejemplo de hecho clarísimo
para ver cómo como no se pueden aplicar
las mismas políticas también según qué
países no el gobierno decidió
implementar este pase a partir del 21 de
diciembre para acceder a restaurantes
hoteles bares pero también para acceder
a cosas tan básicas como escuelas o el
transporte público todo esto mientras
sólo el 8 por ciento de la población de
kenia está vacunada y el país además ha
recibido en total unos 10 millones de
dosis de vacunas una cifra totalmente
insuficiente para inmunizar a las más de
30 millones de personas que forman más o
menos su población
adulta la decisión en parte busca
aumentar esta tasa de vacunación pero el
problema quizás no es tan si la gente
quiere vacunarse o no sino en la
disponibilidad de vacunas y también en
por ejemplo pues que hay muchísima
población que vive en la ruralidad que
no puede acceder a estos puntos de
vacunación escuchemos algunas de las
denuncias que llegaba de la población
keniana wangari aquí tiene claro todo
deberían haber hecho una campaña puerta
a puerta como lo hacen con la polio
vacunar de casa en casa en vez de
negarnos a el acceso a los servicios
públicos ya hoy hay algo con unas actas
de acerca del gobierno debe tenernos en
cuenta todos cambio en aborto ni audio
vamos a ver entonces cómo se implementa
o no esta medida mar pero vamos a hablar
de buenas noticias de la vacuna de
países le pregunto qué datos nuevos
tenemos pues la compañía publicó datos
importante recordar que siguen siendo
datos de la misma compañía de un estudio
a medio plazo sobre la protección de
esta vacuna en los jóvenes entre los 12
y los 15 años y los datos la noticia es
buena son datos prometedores básicamente
esta vacuna cuando se dio a estos
jóvenes entre los 12 y los 15 años
protegió del contagio hasta en un 100
un número completo ahora bien detallamos
de dónde viene esa cifra para entenderlo
mejor el estudio se hizo con más de
2.200 participantes se dividieron en dos
grupos los vacunados y los no vacunados
es decir los que recibieron un placebo y
entre los que recibieron un placebo en
vez de la vacuna hubo unos 30 contagios
de kobe 19 entre los que estaban
completamente vacunados hubo 0 contagios
por eso esta cifra del resultado del
estudio es tan redonda son buenas
noticias son datos prometedores pero eso
no quita que cuando la vacuna se
administre a millones de jóvenes
detectemos algunos contagios también en
esta franja de edad pero en cualquier en
cualquier caso es una buena noticia pues
de prevenir los contagios y la
transmisión sin duda mari a nosotros nos
encanta saber qué piensan nuestros
televidentes sobre nuestras secciones
del programa tenemos precisamente una
encuesta en nuestro instagram oficial de
france 24 en español sobre las vacunas
de cubit 19 que queremos saber más pues
básicamente lo que estamos preguntando
esta vez es si hay personas que tienen
dudas alrededor de la vacuna no sé si
están dudando en vacunarse o no no solo
en instagram también pueden responder en
twitter en facebook y en youtube
entonces nuestro objetivo es resolver
estas dudas también de manos de nuestros
asesores científicos y lo pueden hacer
tanto por privado en nuestras redes como
con los hashtags salud desde 24 y
directo américa es de 24 años así es así
que llamamos a que participen en nuestra
encuesta de nuestras redes sociales
sobre la polémica vacuna contra el coi
19 marc muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud nos vemos mañana
con más de esta sección vamos a pasar
ahora a hablar con nuestra segunda
invitada al día